the ending of the Invisible Man doesn't
unfold exactly how you expect but that's
only fitting for Leigh Whannell twisty
horror thriller the invisible man's
ending isn't a straightforward one but
it's the right one for the movie here's
how it goes down spoilers ahead the
invisible man's final showdown seems
simple Cecelia visits Adrian's house for
a meal when Adrian refuses to apologize
to Celia leaves to freshen up while
she's gone
Adrian lifts a knife seemingly against
his will even though he's alone in the
room and slits his own throat
Cecilia returns just in time to watch
him die everything Cecilia does in the
scene is set up earlier in the movie the
security cameras at Adrian used to spy
on Cecilia are now the key to proving
his suicide and throughout the film
Adrian's weapon of choice is a knife
it's only fitting that his story ends
with one and then of course there's the
second invisibility suit that Cecilia
Dawn's the one she found while snooping
around Adrian's mansion
that's why Adrian's comeuppance is so
satisfying in the final scene Cecilia is
using all of Adrian's tricks against him
she even sends Adrian to the grave with
his own catchphrase during the meal
Adrian pleads for forgiveness saying
that he's sorry Izzy though because
everything that Adrian does in the scene
screams that he hasn't changed at all
he's still choosing Cecilia's meals for
her and still trying to Gaslight her he
blames Cecilia for her own trauma
deflecting responsibility and painting
himself as the real victim
this is all textbook behavior for an
abuser and it's not any different than
what Adrian was doing while he was in
the invisibility suit from all
indications Adrian hasn't learned a
thing thankfully Cecilia doesn't fall
for it she's moved beyond Adrian and
she's no longer looking back The
Invisible Man is framed like an
empowerment story at the beginning in
the movies Cecilia lives in fear of
Adrian even after she escaped she's so
traumatized that she can't even leave
the house Adrian staff gives her solace
but it's only once the Invisible Man
begins attacking that Cecilia finally
musters the courage resolving confidence
that she needs to fight back by the end
in the movies Cecilia and Adrian have
switched places Cecilia is now the
hunter Adrian is a prey that's one way
to look at it anyway another is that
despite losing his life Adrian won
the Cecilia we met near the beginning of
the film the kind compassionate woman is
gone her sister is dead she has blood on
her hands her emotions have been
replaced by a calm cool detached Ness
it goes even further than that though as
we've seen Cecilia has learned how to
use all of Adrian's tricks including how
to get away with murder that's not to
say that she's the same as Adrienne that
dude is still much much worse but
Adrienne obviously broke Cecilia and
it's not clear if she'll ever truly
recover as the thriller the Invisible
Man is taut and well paced but as a
result it doesn't always take the time
to explain everything most notably
Cecilia is big five million dollar
payout a key piece of Adrian's plan to
torment Cecilia and one of the key
drivers of the plot isn't mentioned in
the last bit of the movie presumably
Adrian's will still applies the second
time he dies but we'll never know for
sure if Sydney ends up with enough cash
to go to her dream College same goes for
how Adrian faked his death the first
time presumably the deception was
convincing enough to fool the police
Cecilia's revenge doesn't quite hold up
if you think about it either the
authorities know that Cecilia and Adrian
have been mixed up with an invisibility
suit which was used to commit a violent
crime even with the seemingly definitive
camera footage and James's testimony
there's going to be a pretty thorough
investigation and Cecilia is sure to be
a prime suspect
maybe that's why Cecilia takes off after
making the 911 call still while none of
those loose threads really matter as
much as the invisible man's main story
are concerned they're proof that the
movies tidy ending isn't quite as slick
as it seems
Leigh Whannell is the Invisible Man
doesn't need a sequel by the end Cecilia
and Adrian's stories are complete but
this is Hollywood and if the Invisible
Man is a hit it's hard to imagine that
Sony and Blum House won't try to build a
franchise out of it this movie comes
along catering for people who are just
walking in it for the first time and the
horror fans are like I know all this
stuff
clearly Whannell knows how it goes in an
interview we had with Whannell he told
us that the only Invisible Man material
he consumed before writing the 2020
reboot was HG Wells's original novel and
James Wales 1933 feature film he
basically ignored all the sequels which
is probably for the best
I - gesundheit
none of those sequels really follow the
plot established in 2020s the Invisible
Man the idea of someone else getting
their hands on the invisibility
technology and embarking on a whole new
adventure could be the way forward
definitely do not expect the straight-up
remake of the Invisible Woman even
though that seems like the most obvious
direction to go the 1940 feature is
actually a screwball comedy in which a
former model uses invisibility to stop
some idiot gangsters a suitable
follow-up to a moody paranoid thriller
it certainly ain't of course there's
already an Invisible Woman feature film
and development at Universal but don't
be fooled this isn't a second act for
Elisabeth Moss as Cecelia Cass it's an
entirely different project the project
comes from Elizabeth Banks who is set to
direct and star in a more traditional
and visible woman remake for Universal
Hollywood Reporter says the movie is
like quote Thelma and Louise meets
American Psycho thanks this film is
another attempt by Universal to
revitalize its classic horror properties
after Tom Cruise's The Mummy sank the
studio's plan dark universe franchise
right out of the gate it's not a
follow-up to one l's movie but
considering how good the Invisible Man
turned out to be with its smart sparse
approach to horror
hopefully it follows his lead check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]